con el sonido de las granadas y disparos
al aire del grupo talibán de fondo unos
diez mil afganos aglutinan en el
aeropuerto de kabul en busca de una
huida cada vez más desesperada pese a la
presencia de tropas extranjeras y el
anuncio de que la otan mantendrá tropas
en la capital para asegurar las
evacuaciones los insurgentes controlan
las calles y principales entradas
obstaculizando el paso de los civiles
extender le digo a la gente que se quede
en sus casas y no vengan a esta zona es
una situación muy muy caótica ahora
mismo y espero que la situación mejore
porque veo que los niños están muriendo
es muy terrible
si bien cientos de afganos en su mayoría
de trabajadores que ayudaron a las
fuerzas extranjeras ya se encuentran en
países de europa o norteamérica
naciones unidas- alarmas sobre la
situación de aquellos civiles que están
atrapados en afganistán cuya
vulnerabilidad precede al control
talibán
se necesita urgentemente un mayor apoyo
a la respuesta humanitaria dentro de
afganistán para prestar asistencia al
pueblo afgano que incluye alrededor de
medio millón de desplazados sólo este
año la gran mayoría de afganos no puede
salir del país por los es
un pedido con el que coincide este
refugiado en italia
hay otras personas que necesitan ser
salvadas por lo que si algún país como
italia consigue salvarla será algo muy
bueno una gran esperanza para otras
personas que de esta manera podrían
sobrevivir los talibán han llegado y la
gente no está segura ni las mujeres ni
los jóvenes que quieren vivir en
libertad 'la tribuna' dona
pese a la crítica situación humanitaria
en afganistán
muchas mujeres uno de los grupos
poblacionales más golpeados por el yugo
talibán desafían a los islamistas con
protestas públicas como símbolo de
resistencia